ROGER MARTINEZ:
Last time, we talked
about how you can
secure your service
accounts by understanding the
IAM roles associated with them.
One of the roles I mentioned
was a service account key admin,
a role that lets you create
service account keys that
could then be used
to allow users
to authenticate as
a service account
from outside Google Cloud.
That sounds kind of
risky, doesn't it?
Today, I'll go over
a few fundamentals
of managing service account keys
so that you can reduce the risk
and keep your
service account safe.
And in case you want to minimize
using service account keys,
I'll show you how,
in some cases,
you can authenticate
as a service account
without having to create
or distribute keys at all.
Let's get to it.
I'm going to tell you what's
what with service account
keys and impersonation.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Before we dive into
service account keys, let's
talk about the security
implication of using them.
For users that already have
access to your project,
there aren't any
special roles that they
need to use service account
keys to act as them.
That means that any user in
your project's IAM policy
has access to that key
will be able to utilize
the corresponding service
account to access APIs
and services.
This can be
especially problematic
if the service account has
broad access to your project.
And on top of that, once
you distribute a key,
it can be difficult to
make sure that it doesn't
fall into the wrong hands.
For this reason,
it's a best practice
to rotate keys as
often as possible.
Rotating keys is a
process of swapping out
old keys for new ones and then
deactivating the old ones.
It's a simple
three-step process.
First, you generate new keys for
each of your service accounts.
Then you replace the
old key with the new one
wherever it's being used.
And last, you
delete the old ones
so that they don't work anymore.
So, how do we generate
new service account keys?
If you're using Google Cloud
Console or the G Cloud CLI,
you have two ways of creating a
key for your service account--
uploading your own or having
Google generate it for you.
If you want to
upload your own key,
you'll use GCloud IAM service
accounts keys upload, followed
by the file with your public
key and the IAM account flag,
to indicate the service
account you want to use it for.
You will need to
upload the private key.
It's up to you to
keep it secured.
It will be used to access your
project as a service account.
To have Google generate
a new key pair,
you'll use GCloud IAM
service accounts keys create
followed by the
output file you want
to save your private key
to and the IAM account
flag to indicate the service
account you want the key for.
This will immediately
save the private key
to the file indicated.
This will be the only time the
private key is provided to you.
Remember, it's
your responsibility
to keep the private
keys safe and secure.
The output file, when you have
Google Cloud generate a key,
will look like this.
It's a JSON object with fields
like project ID, private key ID
and private key itself, the
service account email and ID,
and more.
Note that the key in
this format can be used
for running GCloud commands.
If you want to use a
key to access any cloud
resources using
the REST API, you
can generate a key by
sending an HTTP POST
request to the
corresponding API URL,
along with your access token
that will turn a private key.
The format of the JSON
you get with this method
is a bit different.
We recommend that you just use
the same method you're going
to use for future API calls.
Otherwise, you have
to edit the key
to match the desired format.
When you want to delete an old
key, you'll need the keys ID,
GCloud IAM service accounts keys
list, followed by the service
account will spit out the
keys that currently exists
for that service
account by key ID,
along with the date of creation
and the date of expiration.
With that, you can delete
it with GCloud IAM service
accounts keys delete,
followed by the key ID
from the previous output.
The old key is now unusable to
authenticate as your service
account, but if you replace
it in all the places
that you need it to work,
that shouldn't be a problem.
If you need a way for users
to access service accounts
but you're concerned
about having
to manage service account
keys, there is some good news.
For some use cases, the
key really isn't required.
Instead, users can create
short-lived service account
credentials.
Short-lived service
account credentials
have a limited
lifetime, with durations
of just a few hours or shorter.
They also generate less risk
than long-lived credentials,
such as service account keys.
A user of the service account
token creator role on a service
account will be able
to take advantage
of short-lived credentials.
For example, they can
generate an OAuth 2 access
token for the service account
to access the Google Cloud REST
API as a service account.
Additionally, a
user of this role
can use the impersonate
service account
flag on any GCloud command
to run it as a service
account, no keys required.
Depending on your
organizational needs,
you could reduce,
or even eliminate,
the use of service account
keys, and in effect,
reduce the attack
surface of your projects.
By understanding
service account keys
and implementing a solid
rotation process for them,
you'll be taking some major
steps in securing your project
service accounts.
If you're able to cut
out keys where you can
and take advantage of
short-lived service account
credentials, then
that's even better.
We've covered a lot of ground
in the last four episodes
about service accounts.
Hopefully, by now, you've
got a pretty good idea
of what they are and
how to best manage them
in your Google Cloud projects.
Next time, we'll
dive a little deeper
in an extended
episode, where we'll
see service accounts in action.
See you soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]